جاء الرئيس الامريكي لولايه ميشيغن شمالي
الولايات المتحده لهذه الولايه المتارجح
انتخابيا على مدى تاريخها جاء ليطلب مجددا
ود الناخبين
المحليين اليوم يتحدث امام اتحاد عمال
السيارات واعطوه اصواتهم وزكو ترشيحه
للانتخابات الرئاسيه المقبله في نوفمبر
لكن واقع الناخبين العرب من الفلسطينيين
واللبنانيين واليمنيين وباقي المسلمين من
باقي الاقليات يضمون الرئيس الامريكي
بمشهد انتخابي جديد هذه الاصوات من العرب
والمسلمين التي اعطت فوزا باهرا عام 2020
امام ترامب للرئيس بايدن هذه المره تريد
وتقول وتعلن مرارا وتكرارا انها ستحجب
صوتها عن الديمقراطيين وعن الرئيس بايدن
ولنستمع لما قاله لنا اليوم احد الناشطين
كان ممكن ان يكون هناك فرصه لجو بايدن قبل
ان يستشهد 30,000 فلسطيني في غزه الان لا
يوجد هناك اي فرصه لجو بايدن سوف نعاقبه
ونجعل منه رئيس لدوره واحده وسوف نقرن
خسارته بالمجازر التي ترتكب ضد الشعب
الفلسطيني في غزه بدعم كامل من جو
بايدن البيت الابيض لم يستمع لتلك المطالب
وبدا العرب اذا يلعبون اللعبه الانتخابيه
ويدركون ان لهم صوتا في الولايات المتحده
وبالتالي يريدون استخدام هذا الصوت
والاداره الامريكيه ادركت منذ مده ان النخ
العربي والمسلم بشكل عام لن يصوت للرئيس
بايدن في ترشحه الثاني للرئاسه كان هناك
اقتراح في واشنطن ان يتم لقاء بين وزير
الخارجيه بلينكن وزعماء الجاليه العربيه
المسلمه المحليه هنا في ولايه مشيك مره
اخرى رفض العرب والمسلمون وينون كما
يقولون لنا هنا عقاب الرئيس بايدن نصر
حسين الجزيره ور مشيكن